foreign
honest to the commentaries for secret
Invasion uh
on Harris uh by my side and yeah we're
gonna tell you um everything you missed
from Secret Invasion episodes one two
three four five and mercifully six uh we
are also going to show you delete scenes
from The Honest trailer we're gonna have
some q a so any questions you may have
like why uh those uh put those in the
chat and then um uh we'll tease you with
next week's honest trailer
um look
always always a good time anyway look
this was my least favorite Marvel thing
in a long time and I think that it I
it's a victim of high expectations
because I think when you get Sam Jackson
Olivia Coleman Don Cheadle and you're
like we're doing a thriller like a tense
taught spy Thriller it's more grounded
it's not gonna end in a big CGI goo
punch him up
um who's who we don't know uh alliances
will be forged and broken and anyone
could be a scroll
it was not that yeah you know who every
scroll is in the first episode except
for Roadie
um yeah and then it's just what was this
what would you call this I I I mentioned
this while while it was going on I think
that there in the same way that that
Boba Fett Star Wars show was like we're
gonna do a crime show but now really
we're gonna talk like stop committing
those guys we're gonna take like the
tropes and the ideas and the settings of
a crime show but really just make a Star
Wars I'm a chrome Kingpin but not for
Crime for enforcing the laws of crime
wait I'm a corpse it's like it's like
those is it cake where they they make
the cake look like a chicken it doesn't
it's not chicken it says okay it just
looks kind of like a chicken and then
you cut into it you're like that's the
thing is all these Disney shows are like
it's just a Disney show inside but when
you cut into it they're like making it
look like Tinker Taylor soldier's fine
you're like oh cool a special oh it
looked like a specialist in the sense
that it was very gray a lot of gray and
we were in Moscow so that's vaguely
they're taking the the aesthetic
trappings of spycraft and that genre but
they're not they're not dedicating
themselves to it they're not doing the
details they're not really figuring out
that kind of story they're doing their
same punch them up obvious sort of by
the Numbers kind of Marvel story it's
just like with a dusting of that to sort
of trick you into thinking you're
watching something that's genuinely
different it and and it's not it's just
it's so it's so oversimplified like that
the whole show opens with a guy
who we've never even met like some Rando
yelling at Martin Freeman it's not
really Martin Freeman yelling at him
like the entire plot they're all Scrolls
this one's a scroll there's a secret
Invasion and their Scrolls they're
basically laying it on it like they
don't they don't trust you to get it or
to have any patience and figure out what
the show is about over the course right
it's got it all plotted out on his wall
and his wall of crazy yeah and it's just
like well that's boring and that's very
superficial it's just a very superficial
take on all of this kind of material and
we've seen way better more thoughtful
deeper versions of it like horses on
Apple right now it's a spy show that's a
lot better than this that's doing the
same stuff so like why do I need this
that's me is a is a cardinal sin against
your show's premise it should be about
who is and who isn't a scroll but the
fact that the audience they tip their
hand to the audience right away about
everybody you meet every scroll
character yeah the the Don Cheadle I
think was meant to be the one the one
reveal we're holding it as like a big
reveal late but it it's also like but he
he's mean he doesn't act like himself
and it so it kind of tips your head and
you know it's going to be somebody that
we've met before 220 million dollars man
well that that's a whole that's a whole
separate issue where it's like did you I
was reading a Forbes the other day had a
piece
um Foundation I don't know if you watch
the Apple TV plus Foundation show I
really like it uh it costs about 45
million per season and it is friggin
enormous it's like space and there's
action and Lee Pace is getting naked in
wrestling dudes they're like that's
worth 20 million right there it's a big
show
Planet you're going to different planets
and there's like you know Mountain stuff
and underwater stuff like it feels it
doesn't feel like a show where it's
three people standing in a room it feels
like you're really going places so they
can do that for 45 I it doesn't make any
sense The Secret of Asian clubs
yeah I mean okay Sam Jackson first
series what 10 million 15 million and
they were saying like it was a lot of
reshoots like they shot a lot of it and
then they didn't like what they had and
then they got everybody back and they
re-shot a bunch of it and that is really
expensive you know so you but even if
they did it twice but even if you
doubled it that's still over a hundred
million per version and that's still too
much yeah especially for what we get
like not a single standout action scene
except the finale which was for the
wrong reasons yeah it stands out because
it looks goofy absolutely right like
it's just it's it doesn't and a secret
Invasion unlike Foundation it really
does feel like the kind of show where
it's just characters standing around in
rooms a lot talking to each other like
it doesn't you're you don't really feel
like it's like globetrotting and you're
going to a lot of different kinds of
places and there isn't really that kind
of diversity of what you're saying I
could feel them giving up on the show
because it starts off uh just look at
the run times where it's like hour 56
minutes 54 minutes
40 30 30. yeah those last three episodes
nothing happens there's an ambush next
episode they literally run out of story
and like a spy thing it should be like
endlessly like oh upending your
expectations and we didn't know this
part was coming in we're basically
preparing for an attack for three
episodes yeah I mean the real like
narrative meet and twists and turns
weren't even really character driven it
was just going back in time to find out
more things Nick Fury falsely promised
in 1995. yeah there's more things he
lied to them about yeah he's not come
out of this looking very good let's go
to the trailer all right
we'll get into it we'll get into it
secret invasion
that is what it's like with Spectrum
internet that's how long you see the
Marvel films fail at the box office the
CEO suggests they've cheapened the brand
and let's be honest you probably started
skipping shows entirely yep now get
ready for a series that proves if it's
not time to scrap the whole thing Disney
should at least pause until their next
batch of Chris is ready
foreign
[Music]
secret Invasion ew are those AI
generated titles gross yeah
bad start put a bad taste in everyone's
mouth yeah right they they could have
recovered if the show was really good
but why put yourself in a position where
you have to record it just it's so it's
such a what a weird call that was yeah
and like I guess there was no money left
over because they'd spent you know the
GDP of a small country on this or I do
kind of feel like there was you know
like in in February I don't remember
exactly like January February of this
year when those AI apps were like brand
new there was like a three-week period
where we all even me the most cynical AI
guy there we're all we're like whoa you
can type anything in and it almost works
that's almost like a doggy like what we
all had that and so I feel like maybe
this was approved during that where they
were like well this trend is Gonna Last
Forever people are never gonna get tired
of this like buttery weird loose
diarrhea looking style animation where
it almost looks like a human face before
it becomes monstrous like what just Sam
Jackson looks like Ian miles challenge
yeah this is perfect even if you had
like animators like I even if you had
that as your aesthetic like oh make it
look like it's that weird AI like sort
of where everything's slipping
psychedelic into the next image but but
have real people do it don't actually do
an AI not a great especially during a
strike not a great time for that to come
out it still looks like junkie like I'm
not saying it'll never get better but it
doesn't look good enough for TV today no
and yeah it just looks like I could make
it on my computer it's like you can type
in the right prompt right make me an
extremely gooey version right like what
if green people but you know gooey
oh well uh all right keep going
Fury is back from space station and
everyone agrees that he sucks now the
one with power the one with ability the
theory is gone he's traumatized oh my
God
oh no and really effing cold these Watch
Dogs walks with the limbs can barely
seal the good oil the fact that you
don't know tells me all I need to know
about this new rather old Nick Fury why
don't you hobble your ancient ass on out
of here before I have you defenestrated
in the latest sequel that thinks
audiences want to see their Heroes as
pathetic washed up sad sex do you want
to get soup
yeah Fury sucks and it turns out he
always has sucked yeah that that I
really don't like is like okay if you I
get you want to do the Logan like beat
down one last adventure but we got to
make him like he's real out of practice
and he's gonna have to do a comeback I I
get that but they're like they're
retconning like Nick Fury always sucked
we just made him look good for those
early Marvel movies like that's messed
up man I don't want that to be true he
was blackmailing shape-shifting aliens
and defeating him yeah well he just sat
there and got lit up on old grandpappy's
bourbon there's a there's a scene where
Ben Mendelson as Talos is like really
ripping into him like I did everything
you didn't do anything I made you and
then that character gets murked in the
next episode so like you're you're
building up this other guy over to like
this was the real power behind Nick Fury
all along if you're a second he doesn't
even fight back at that point he's just
like yeah well you need you need my ass
now I saved your life for that last
scene you done being mean to me so we
can finish the show that's literally
like what he says and and but it's like
but so you're you're you're like in
using wrestling terms like you're using
Nick Fury to put over Talos but that cow
is gonna die there's no need to put him
over Nick Fury will never and then yeah
they're just taking him apart with the
his eyes from a cat scratch he's a fraud
he's a frog he's a total fraud he was
like like that was like your most badass
character people were always like we
want to see more of Victory but that not
like this like they wanted to see him
being cool not like the the real story
is pathetic also uh punches like a 75
year old male that can't be avoided I
mean yeah even in Captain Marvel when
they had de-aged him the body yeah he
remembers still still running like an
old guy face looks young that's why they
can't see Jesus to be like walking in at
the end or like an opportune time saying
something cool but that's always who he
was he was never the action star so it's
like yeah I think he had some like his
original Comics run right in the in the
MCU he was always like the guy coming in
at the end like haha I have one secret
thing you didn't know about my mask your
plan that's who Nick Fury is and that's
what we want to see it he said he's it's
the opposite he's constantly being
knocked on his heels I didn't see this
coming yeah it's really bad all right
made me sad keep going the event so if
Captain Marvel a movie you totally
remember the events of right right the
aliens who look like Piccolo's left nut
are still stranded on Earth Fury has
phoned in finding them a new planet I
knew that a few years of searching that
that was no other planet out there for
you damn
and he won't even carve out a chunk of
Norway to crash on now Scrolls have
infiltrated our society to find a
long-term home in the second Marvel show
about how refugees are secretly
terrorists
one people only my own skin home in my
own skin uh-oh the villains are in the
right again quick do the thing
there were still people in there is the
only languages people understand that's
better keep stay good
look I I hate the type of criticism
that's like let's pick apart the
villain's plan because it doesn't make
sense sometimes it's funny
um but the Scrolls plan in this movie
well it's
it's okay there's a million of them
already on Earth and they're the UK's
prime minister yeah they're incredibly
influential figures throughout
government uh media everything you'd
need or want to maybe like
carve out a bit of land for yourself or
like pass some anti-scroll
discrimination laws and their plan is to
start World War Three because they can
technically survive in a nuclear hell
right I get yeah they're they're like
they have cockroach power and so their
plan is like we'll all nuke one another
and then they can like live in the
wreckage but it's like but like but it's
a perfectly functioning civilized planet
right now you don't have to do that you
could a million of them could easily
integrate into they have already it's
kind of it I I think that's why he had
to be so mad at fury because it's sort
of like they don't really need to do
this it's just graphic is so angry that
he's insisting that they do it and
everybody else is kind of going along
and these are the sorts of things you
could develop in like a real spy show
all these conflicting agendas and people
who you know overlapping interest but
not entirely and like those are the
things that fuel these kinds of stories
they're just not interested in the Deep
details it's starting the whole MCU is
starting to suffer from the fact that we
have no sense of what the non-superhero
world is like at this point right
outside of like Peter Parker's friends
there aren't really any humans just
dealing with the fact that well there is
a a galactic-sized alien that's like
coming out half hatched out of the earth
and there's there's as Guardians there's
aliens they're superheroes running like
New York got invaded by aliens and stuff
that really they can't handle Scrolls
they can't like there's anti-scroll yeah
sentiment that they would they would
chase them out with pitchforks like I
don't buy it no yeah the the well that
that's the other thing is again like an
argument going on among the characters
about like would Humanity accept
squirrels not like I think that's the
sort of thing that could feel the show
like this like that makes a lot of sense
but it's weird that they've come in with
the hero of the show Nick Fury he's the
one who's like no no humans are terrible
we'd never accept these squirrels the
only option is
get rid of them get them out uh and
nobody else is really there to like
count we don't have an alternate the
only reason I can think of that is that
they're saving more scroll reveals and
man is that going to be funny when in
like uh you know Kang's Avengers movie
like somebody turns into a scroll
everyone's like ah I get I mean
definitely this ends with Olivia Coleman
and Emilia Clark like we're gonna work
together and like this story's not over
and like how much you guys want to bet
it's like but it's more like the The
Immortals are gonna walk through that
door is that what was that with the big
dog yeah yeah yeah I'd be like maybe
Gaia pops up again and stuff absolutely
guy is going back to her home planet I
think the scrolls are gonna find their
whole plan sooner yeah well that's the
other thing is even just even without us
adding in Milky Way context like just in
the MCU they've established there's a
lot of planets I mean not all of them
are really that busy Titan is empty or
half empty yeah totally empty we've seen
Titan which all the the like it's got
some grab wonky gravity issues but it's
survivable and there's nobody there
vormir also that's that you gotta yeah
just avoid Soul Stone Mountain there's a
whole planet there yeah all right all
right yeah they can find a spot they can
live in nowhere nowhere they can go on
that weird asteroid Morag where uh
Star-Lord goes and finds that infinity
stone there's just those little little
like mammal guys running around that he
grab you know I guess that that plant's
gone with um Glenn Close she's dead off
camera uh well no I mean we they killed
all the humans on uh where no wherever
Nova was I forget the name of that
planet they killed the people there but
it could still there's room for Scrolls
what about what about high
evolutionaries planet with all the like
uh hybrid animal drug dealers what about
Montana
there's not many people they'll be fine
yeah well right there was a whole there
was a whole like Atlantean civilization
like name or civilization just went
underwater they didn't even know about
him
anyways
for a spy Thriller made entirely out of
spy Thriller cliches where everyone has
to be stupid for the plot to work last I
checked Roadie is a scroll
what and even the scroll stick with one
face
I'm gonna try a white guy for a Russian
soldier Okay as Fury and friends will do
anything they can to stop World War III
without calling the Avengers
the choices I mean I know it's just like
casting and who cares but they're all in
Russia and it's like you got an
Australian black guy English accent
nobody is like I'm gonna try to blend in
with Russian folk well because they're
scroll like the whole bit their
advantage is they could be anybody yeah
and and yes it's like all been on that
cafe and Moscow for 28 didgeridoses
through the entire through the entire
series
they keep doing this where like the
squirrels pick one human identity and
then stick with it the whole time when
they could be any they could be we've
established they can be anybody like
they could all turn into Nick Fury if
they wanted to like be interesting yeah
that'd be a cool scene just the idea
that they're all sticking to their one
Persona so we can always recognize who's
who is like it really yeah defeats its
own purpose that's Jacob said all right
keep going
depending on these superheroes to swoop
in and save our asses because then you
have to admit he's been scraping all
their goo into a cup and hiding in his
grave imagine looking cap in the eye and
telling him you scraped his gew the
shame you'd feel all right pause I want
to pause right there too doesn't it
so much of like phase one especially was
about like recreating the super soldier
serum and how difficult it would be to
make more Captain but like that's why we
Falcon winter sold right that's why we
don't have an army of Captain America's
already because we can't recreate
erskine's whatever magic super serum
but then this suggests that all you'd
really have to do is collect avenge your
blood and you could just synthesize
literally any make anybody a clone of
any Avenger it's like what but that
doesn't make any sense how are you just
gonna reverse the entire story of the
franchise so far I also don't understand
why it was such a long and laborious
search because the search wasn't for the
vial the search was for like the gravic
had been searching for their goo for a
long time yeah it's like I'm sure it
wasn't it the whole thing went down at
like The Avengers compound and it was
yeah it was the Battle of Earth and end
game not a tough place to spot right
like oh there's some go on a rock like
let's oh oh look we got a groovius pip
or whatever
their computer database has everybody's
name in a Co-op City and like they
weren't introducing themselves
yeah nobody was like showing up like hey
call obsidian this is my blood does
anyone know drax's name on Earth
any sense even and they have like they
have like species names they're like oh
Flora gigantis is Groot like what do you
think this is so stupid like that's the
whole thing right when her arm turns
into drags weren't those tattoos yes oh
yeah oh no she also like physical
characteristics of the I think there's
that who who's the wizard guy or ebony
mom she gets his rings
it's not genetic those are that's
jewelry oh man it's just stupid it's
like that's what I mean like spy stuff
more than a lot of other genres it
really it kind of is about the specifics
and it's about like things we didn't
notice in the little details it's like a
little bit of a magic trick like oh I
didn't know this detail was going to be
important but then an hour later ah what
a [__] now whenever you watch it I can
tell oh she was a scroll and they're
just not doing that here like they're
it's just like they're cheating it
they're just trying they want it to be
anybody can appreciate it
internationally if you're four or 45 and
so it's just got to be like very
accessible and there's none of that but
those are that's what makes this kind of
stuff fun oh well
okay keep going oh that's about more
than two old guys yelling about
off-screen promises they broke well not
entirely have you lost your reptilian
ass mind hey what would you have done me
cause you
because
you got any more if you just want to
hurl my way
going for a walk
meet you Clark who co-stars as Gaia
because she can't turn down the chance
to learn another made-up language
she's a scroll terrorist until a couple
days before the finale where she gets
almost every Power in the MCU no way
that's gonna bite Us in the ass later or
uh look cool on camera
it's not Amelia Clark's fault but man
like she's been she's really good and
has been a part of some really bad thing
although I didn't love her Sarah Connor
in uh the old Genesis yeah but I think
in Game of Thrones she's fantastic she's
not bad in this
um but yeah it it they don't it feels
like things don't know how to use her
like Khaleesi Daenerys was such an
iconic character and she's so great but
I don't I don't feel like any of the
other projects she's been in they they
know like what to do to get that Emilia
clarkness that we all like out and this
feels like it's such a it's such a bland
character it's kind of there's really
nothing to Gaia other than like I never
really felt determined the familial
connection between her and uh Talos
which is what it's really built on is
like that was her father like yeah why
did they whatever
okay keep going it's not her it's not
her fault she's great but it's it's also
like that big fight at the end like she
so what like it's just hard to put
yourself in her perspective like she's
injected with the blood of all of these
aliens she's never met how does she know
like oh there's a guy Drax who's strong
I'm gonna get his arm so I can punch
better wouldn't you be like Hulk is the
strongest how is this working when she
impersonates Nick Fury she got all of
his memories did you get all everything
he knows there's there they have a
machine they have a machine that does
that but I don't know if she did that to
him maybe because she seems to be able
to carry on think if you think about it
Nick Fury is her dad's friend so Uncle
Nick if you had to impersonate your
Dad's friend like with somebody your
Dad's friend knew really well that would
be really hard like I don't think I
could be tough like I know some stuff
about my dad's friends but not that not
those kind of details where I could be
like believably having a conversation
with somebody they've known for 20 years
yeah one boy they'd be like we never we
never fished together at Snake River
yeah why do you keep saying it's me
the base yeah
I got my nickname like
I didn't know them in that context it
would be really that's a really hard so
but think about it her performance she's
acting like her father's friend very
believably but she's also she's
pretending to have radiation sickness so
like that's that's quite a performance
that she's giving that's awesome guys
all of like uh like real Roadie and real
office Tim and all those guys like how
are they not melting from radiation
sickness scrolls are impervious they're
okay
when they're um in the little cages in
the nuclear reactor yeah no that's a
plot hole okay
okay keep going winning the fight as
British spymaster Sonia fallsworth
Olivia Coleman summons hope like
strength to carry the series on her back
armed with the one comedy bid of saying
mean things in a friendly way I'm very
good at being your bestie I'm also
devilishly good at being not your bestie
well now that's confirmed
let's party shall we she's good I mean
she's very good at this bit
that's what all the podcasts are about
is she cheeky yes all favorites return
like office Tim who's been a scroll
since who gives a [__] Maria Hill who's
bravely sacrificed to give her boss a
little extra Pizzazz Sharon Carter who
no she's not a scroll so she just
randomly turned into an arms dealer yes
okay and Colonel Rhodes who's revealed
to have been a scroll since at least the
death of Tony Stark and maybe even
earlier honestly they've been hinting
that he's a shapeshifter since day one
that would have been so incredible if
they brought back terrorists like the
real Roadies down here like here he is
you guys didn't notice that it looked
totally different yeah
uh and then he tells you one plus one
equals three yeah
teaches the world Cardiology oh that
would have made it all all better in my
mind yeah I mean at this point with the
Ralph boner stuff like they're all
they're right on the edge of just giving
us what we want anyway in terms of like
the meta jokes like just bring back
Terrence how or whatever yeah what do
you got to lose everyone just uh just
shrug their shoulders when when Roadie
showed up with a different face yeah oh
yeah oh wait yeah but that was nice
scroll mind control they got in our
heads yeah
oh well okay keep going I've been
wondering about that Bruce Banners
without any tension about a hero who
thinks humans are full of hate there's
not enough room or Tolerance on this
planet for another species plunges Earth
into a race war
with one of the good ones while we're
left to pick up the pieces because it
turns out Nick Fury always has his eye
on the bigger picture when can he get
his next drink
I'm pretty sure you recollect my drink
of choices
how about a drink instead I wouldn't say
no I wanted to share my favorite liquid
lunch with you Happy Van Winkle
this is a tasty bourbon stirring
mace winded game of clones double in a
blue suit Kingsley bit adieu no no
I want to point out something about how
cheap this looked for a 220 million
dollar show or uh because there's so
many superheroes in Galactic overlords
and stuff no one gives a [__] about the
US president because that guy rolls in
into Moscow like four SUVs deep yeah
like no air support he's taken out by
like some foot soldiers and then he's
guarded by Roadie who is also his chief
of staff
really they're really playing faster
this was like what is roadie at this
point like because everywhere I look
they've never he's a top Air Force
official like he's like a yeah big guy
in the air that's all but but like he's
acting like he's the Jo he's all the
Joint Chiefs he wrote a speech for us
he's the he's the white house chief of
staff he's you know he he's the head of
stays like this and there's no one else
Ontario State he's the Secretary of
Defense like there's usually at least
three or four people talking to the
president it just looks so so cheap and
it's like the president gets basically
shot or messed up or something in this
attack and they put him in like a rinky
dink Hotel uh yeah even a random
Hospital in the middle of Russia yeah
don't get him out of there it's it's
it's so I can only imagine that just
nobody cares at this point about the
president that's the only in Universe
one that makes sense it's like well
we're ruled by these Uber mentions so
who cares about what laws it just feels
like yeah they went in and these are
like these are TV shows they don't they
don't need to be like a movie they could
do any Hospital set we've got sitting
around just throw president dermit in
there you can't even fill the room with
like a comms guy like like some funny
people you should definitely have one or
two other people around the president
advisor guys in the room or just they
don't need dialogue but like it's really
silly and then the one time they do give
Roadie somebody else it's like some like
another Air Force the Admiral next door
was like all these she it's a woman who
gets one line and then she's just there
forever go away yeah like you idiot you
gotta launch the nukes yeah like what it
doesn't it just doesn't feel right you
know okay uh yeah keep going shouldn't
this be Julie Louis Dreyfus spy wife
playmaker and most MCU fans at this
point I was told this phase would be
over
Invasion of the Body matchers
I think hopia ran that through it so
cool now Fury Keeps The Avengers goo
hidden in his grave and his coat in
another grave and his eye patch in
another grave and his gun in another
great feels like that's too many graves
for just one outfit oh I got these all
over the place you know dead men need
options that's four grave bills that
you're paying and then worldwide yeah
he's got so many graves out there it's
like his monthly his monthly plot
out of control oh that was secret
invasion
that sucked
um can we can we stop doing these I
don't want to do anything I don't want
to watch videos anymore I'm tired
definitely done with those uh Loki
season two they'll bring me back with
low because I like Loki season one we're
getting some kind of exciting McDonald's
tie-in I don't know if you saw that ad
if McDonald's is teasing some kind of
Loki season two collab we're gonna get a
Loki Multiverse Burger yeah we didn't
torture the cows or whatever the Loki
and Sylvie burgers
okay
um hamburgers eat people and Rand
McNally yes
yeah let's say let's just go right out
of me
thank you for watching please subscribe
like And subscribe to watch the slope
estate deterioration of us and the MCU
um many more of these Disney Plus shows
yeah we made a funny song you should
watch the character song oh yeah really
fun uh extra video coming out next week
with next week's honest trailer I hope
you guys like
um and now let's see if we have any
outtakes from Secret imitation
starring
Samuel old Jackson no Action Jackson
black in the USSR mother Gaia conchito
one night and news Growers sneaky
blinders or cop then metal certain
rudely denge fallsworth Bentley the old
scroll and chain once you go black you
never mind Mighty Morphin powered
strangers
cute and on
twins
so Fury never told the Avengers about
his wife and what did you want
to call myself beloved
just like Hawkeye in a secret family and
Tony Stark's daughter and Bruce Banner's
son while the secrecy aren't they all
friends was happy calling tips into TMZ
or something
yeah a lot of secret or big reveals and
it's like they have a relative yeah like
you have a family like they're work
friends well I forget that they wouldn't
tell the public but like one another the
most insane reveal that they could do at
this point would be that one of the
Avengers has a platonic non-work friend
right
this is scary oh Thor had a roommate I'm
saying they get integrated because like
that was Sam Wilson originally but then
they they ended up getting pulled into
the family gotta join the family
business yeah like Aquafina is going to
get powers by Shang Chi if she doesn't
already they give her like an armor and
a bow they give her like yeah some some
magical weapons yeah they'll figure it
out yeah all right let's move on to the
Q a uh Matan Valencia says why doesn't
Disney just force feige and Iger to
retire they are Disney that's they can't
speed people there is a board there is a
board that could theoretically Force at
least Iger out and then replace him with
somebody who could Force feige out but
uh they just brought Iger back yeah they
they like Iger and all these things are
good I don't know what the timeline is
but like these aren't jpeg shows and
Niger started the whole like we're going
into Disney Plus
strategy uh or we're expanding the MCU
into television yeah I I mean
at this point most of the chappy stuff
has been sort of reversed or like we're
definitely back in Iger town now but uh
yeah I mean I I don't I don't think the
Disney board has lost faith in Bob Iger
I think a lot of what's going on right
now is more like industry-wide and
everybody they all have to figure out
what the next play is because streaming
didn't pan out yeah
um so Adam Halbert asked does Marvel
just generally suck at doing spy stuff I
feel the Russo set ridiculous
expectations with Winter Soldier
yeah well I mean it's a good thriller I
don't think that that was even
Mo does that qualify as a spyman I mean
it's a it's a good movie I don't mean to
knock it but it it's that same it's like
a dusting yeah it's like it's like a
it's gingerly sprinkled with sort of
they go on the lamb but then they're
like fighting a Helicarrier at the end
it's still an MCU movie just with like a
smattering of spy Trope kind of stuff or
conspiracy Thriller kind of material but
it's not it's not fully into that genre
it's Marvel it's is its own genre yeah
uh Adam Hopper rights if the VFX artists
get unionized and demand more time is
their hope we can stop seeing the
floating heads and distorted tracks arms
now this is I think I just saw something
this morning the MCU VFX houses are
unionizing is that they're they're
they're like it's they're taking the
first steps towards that but yes like it
is it is good news and and it like give
us time to finish well yeah what people
don't really think about is how how much
that impacts like the larger decisions
about what is going to get animated
versus what doesn't like you see those
shots of like there was one from this
show where it's Nick Fury holding a gun
that could have like a Sci-Fi looking
gun but they could have easily been
designed by a prop house but if you see
the behind the scenes It's Sammy Jackson
sitting in a green room and he's holding
like a prop that's got marked because
they're gonna come and see
that's that's not because cause there's
no way to build a real gun it's because
a prop person would have been unionized
and that would cost them a lot of money
to pay somebody to build it whereas an
animator a VFX animator is not unionized
it's a lot cheaper to pay that guy to
make a gun in the computer than it would
be to pay a Craftsman to make a gun in
person so if we fix that if everyone was
in the union and there wasn't any
cheaper obviously go with the thing that
makes sense and looks better exactly so
we would fix a lot of these issues just
by not making VFX a shortcut that's
cheaper but by making it just well those
are different artists you'd have to pay
fairly yeah which of course we should do
just because the artists deserve to be
paid fairly but as a side benefit it
would also make the shows and films look
better yep
a lot a lot of a lot of good stuff here
um let's see so we could go yeah Luis
Valenzuela so the human hostages in the
radioactive skull compound they okay
that's just that's why they were also
just like um like Jesse Eisenberg
feeding a senator a Jolly Rancher just
pushing iodine pills in their mouth
I mean you know like they put something
that they've insulated that room yeah
um so they got they got Jared Harris to
come in and teach them about negative
void coefficients so they figured it out
it's true
why and why was Andor the goat well
almost every other Marvel in Star Wars
Disney plus original uh crashed and
burned I wouldn't say every other one
like they they came out to a hot start
with you know you're you had your wand
divisions yeah I think a Loki season one
was pretty good yeah otherwise
everything's been pretty mid to bad yeah
um uh I mean like look I think it's
Android's great they got Tony Gilroy
like yeah and like the guy from House of
Cards and the guy from like they got
great
behind the scenes talent and then they
forced they put their foot down because
they were they had a pedigree and they
couldn't be pushed around they're like
no we're actually going to shoot in a in
a place we're gonna shoot it in a field
yeah we're going to a real field dammit
right yeah I mean however I wasn't there
behind the scenes but whatever Tony
Gilroy did or said however he pitched it
he convinced them to let him work in a
different way than they've been working
and I think from from most people's
perspective release most fans
perspective that I talked to that
definitely seems to be the preferable
way to do these shows yeah
all right uh I'm done talking about this
um there are some great questions but
that we'll never get to because I want
to stop talking about secret Invasion
I'm sorry I think we all should let's
just forget this ever happened yeah and
disappointing just just like um Hulk's
son and oh there was a good question
about uh is uh I think was it someone
someone talked about how is Emilia Clark
gonna join the uh like Harry Styles oh
gym one Harry Styles and Charlize Theron
of like big names that have been
introduced to the MCU but we'll never
see them again like odds will see Emilia
Clark Harry Styles Andrew yeah I feel
like Charlize Theron I I feel like will
probably like there will probably at
some point be a doctor strange three
Cumberbatch has said he's he's down to
come back I think they'll want him for
Kang Dynasty or the next one Secret Wars
I I feel out of all of these that we've
mentioned I feel like Charlie's I have a
decent amount of confidence should be
back Harry Styles wow I would not I
would not count on that no big Eros
movie
I mean just because eternals didn't
didn't do so great I mean there was also
talk about obviously mahershala Ali's
voice as blade pops up in that too and
there was talk about uh kit harington's
Black Knight getting a spin-off movie
and then he and blade Maybe
I would not count on that either no I
would not put money on that uh just
because eternals didn't eternally you're
gonna see uh I don't feel like guy I
what are they gonna do with Gaia I just
don't feel like it's
I don't feel like the skrels have the
juice for another project right the goo
ran out the goo actually is temporary it
doesn't last well the only the the the
like Ben Mendelson is a good actor like
if you were like Hey we're gonna do
another scroll thing with him I'd be
like all right but he's dead and Scrolls
can't change faces that'd be ridiculous
that could that'd be crazy so uh yeah so
I I don't I don't see a lot of more more
hot scroll action in the next few years
I don't think all right uh on that note
let's
um let's watch uh let's let's stick
around until next week where
um we're going to you know a different
medium
um where uh but it's still gonna look
fake as hell yes
anime probably would have looked better
if you just shot some of it that's where
we'll be so throw your cares out
it's Little Mermaid folks we'll see you
next week for The Little Mermaid thanks
for watching bye-bye
there'll be no accusations
friendly crustaceans
[Music]